et pour décrypter les prises de parole
du professeur didier raoult et fabrice
di vizio l'avocat d'une association de
victimes de coronavirus et frédéric
sinclair éditorialiste politique nous
ont rejoints messieurs bonsoir alors
hydroxyles vos routines port du masque
on va bien évidemment y revenir mais
pour commencer un mot peut-être sur la
forme le professeur raoul a refusé le
format d'une table ronde
ils devaient débattre avec deux autres
chercheurs il a déclaré qu'il ne pouvait
pas discuter sereinement avec des gens
qu'il insulte alors quel regard avez
vous porté sur ce choix on va commencer
avec vous fabrice di vizio
je me méfie toujours des gens qui
refusent de débats par nature le chat
vocal le débat c'est mon coeur de métier
et je me méfie toujours des gens qui
refusent de débat le rapporteur la fit
remarquer professeur out la vérité en
tout cas la grippe dominante émergent
souvent du débat et je me méfie toujours
par principe des gens qui refusent le
débat je pense que le professeur out
raté une occasion de la contradiction si
le professeur out est sûre de ses
positions il n'a rien à craindre et donc
le débat ne doit pas effectivement être
un obstacle
frédéric saint clair ils auraient dû
accepter cette cette table ronde selon
vous écouter il aurait dû ça dépend des
objectifs que il ce fils manifestement
il aura échappé à personne que le
professeur raoul tu es temps en marge de
ce système politico médiatique dans
lequel nous sommes quand même un peu
tous prix c'est un scientifique et pour
l'avoir été moi même dans une discipline
complètement différente
il ya un certain nombre de débats qui
vraiment n'apporte rien donc je sais pas
ce qu'elle a dans sa tête quand il
refuse le débat mais ce que je sais
c'est que aller au fond des choses
lorsqu'on est en elle contraintes
médiatiques c'est pas possible on
pourrait par exemple je pourrais vous
proposez là de débattre aujourd'hui de
d'aristote et de et de platon et vous
allez tout de suite me dire que
on va on va tuer débat parce qu'on va
rentrer dans des considérations
techniques qui vont évidemment tout de
suite débordé le cadre de ce que
l'auditoire novice peut comprendre et
donc finalement quelle est l'utilité
ensuite du débat eh bien ça va être de
réussir à faire valoir sa position par
rapport à celle de l'autre on devient
caricatural ont cherché à prendre le
dessus et on perd ce qui est l'essentiel
finalement d'un vrai débat scientifique
qui se fait au travers des publications
cirque eux qui a raison de raout ou de
ses opposants c'est dans la décennie qui
vient
qu'on le saura pour l'instant je suis
pas certain qu'on à grand chose à gagner
de mettre face à face des personnes qui
ne sont pas d'accord si en plus il ya
insultes je suis pas vraiment au courant
de la chose mais si en plus il ya eu
insulte c'est que ça crée en plus un
climat qui n'est pas forcément en autre
en cette période où la société déjà
tendu qui est pas forcément favorable
en tout cas en tout cas on a entendu un
professeur didier raoult le cash comme
il en a l'habitude notamment en taclant
le conseil scientifique je le cite le
conseil scientifique n'a jamais piloté
quoi que ce soit dans la recherche sur
le colis de 19 c'est ce qui l'a dénoncé
qu'est ce qu'il a voulu pointer du doigt
selon vous en critiquant de la sorte
cette instance frédéric saint clair je
pense que il a répété à plusieurs
reprises dans l'est dans les médias dans
l'interview qu'il a donnée le fait qu'il
ne se sentait pas légitime en tant que
porte parole d'un conseil adressé aux
politiques il a dit à plusieurs reprises
je ne suis pas un homme politique j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour ceux qui font
ce métier là mais moi je suis un
scientifique et finalement le conseil
scientifique
il a une position extrêmement
particulière un pouvoir politique pour
être légitime il doit être à part être
honnête dans sa communication et faire
part d'un choix par nature politique
c'est-à-dire qu'ils né de la volonté
populaire et qui a vocation à
représenter un conseil scientifique ou
une parole scientifique c'est
complètement différent
elle dit le vrai et là on a là on a un
vrai problème
au niveau du conseil scientifique c'est
que la science qui prétend dire le vrai
quand c'est une science empirique et
quand on est en période de crise comme
on l'est actuellement
les français découvrent que la science
ne dit pas le vrai en fait elle dit
l'état de ses connaissances à l'instant
t
et puis elle se contredit constamment ce
qui en réalité la réalité de la science
depuis des siècles mais quand on est
dans une période de crise on sent bien
que ça crée une tension particulière et
alors quand on associe cette prétention
à dire le vrai à un pouvoir politique
eh bien on a quelque chose qui fragilise
le pouvoir politique on a bien vu à quel
point il a été difficile pour emmanuel
macron pour edouard philippe pendant
toute cette crise de maintenir un niveau
de crédibilité est suffisant pour des
raisons parfois qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le conseil scientifique mais
simplement par la difficile à difficulté
d'implémenter une politique de santé
publique
quand on découvre une crise et puis
quand on l'est la vie j'allais dire au
jour le jour
fabrice di vizio vous chiez de la tête
il ya quelques minutes mais au fond est
ce que le professeur didier raoult et il
incarne pas finalement cette opposition
entre le politique et le scientifique de
terrain l'homme de terrain est celui
dans les bureaux je crois que professeur
didier rule qui là car ne rien d'autre
que didier rahout je pense qu'il faut
arrêter
il le dit d'ailleurs et donnons lui acte
de ça moi je sais pas si c'est vrai mais
le professeur raout il ya un filet
effectivement médecin il y en a d'autres
en france on dirait pas comme ça mais on
a d'autres en france
quant à savoir si le conseil précise le
professeur raoul tu devais participer
aux conseils scientifiques ou non je
passe qui lui aurait fait quoi ce raout
est un marginal s'est passé par un
défaut il est en marche au sens littéral
et donc je pas très bien à partir du
moment où ils font le choix de se
positionner en marge
ce qu'il aurait fait dans un conseil qui
effectivement par essence obéit à des
règles obéit à des contraintes il a
choisi de s'affranchir de ces
contraintes
eh ben il y en a parfaitement le droit
est donc en cela ne pas faire partie du
conseil scientifique est une bonne chose
ce qui n'enlève rien à la légitimité
d'ailleurs du conseil scientifique
alors il a parlé également de la
recherche je vous propose
de les goûter sur ce sujet de la
recherche et puis on réagit ensuite la
recherche d comme le sport de haut
niveau
oui c'est pas démocratique l'idée que
c'est démocratique si vous voulez alors
dans les phases stationnaire c'est un
des grands grands épistémologique
historien des sciences dit vous savez il
ya trois phases dans le domaine de de la
recherche dans un domaine particulier
il ya une première phase qui est une
phase pionnière est dans la phase
pionnière sont des gens qui sont
audacieux qui brise les lignes qui sont
poids zone et toute leur vie d'accord
c'est les pionniers et puis ensuite il
ya une phase de plateau si vous voulez
dans lequel qui est dite normale dans
lequel les choses avancent petit à petit
on rajoute un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu c'est une phase dans lequel
qui vient collective c'est ce qu'on
appellerait la recherche démocratique
dans lequel et les études
multicentriques avec sept pays européens
chacun rajoute à mme thibout ça c'est la
face du plateau opi malheureusement
après il ya la face du déclin c'est à
dire que le chant s'épuiser puis un
autre chantier qui ne sais c'est comme
ça et c'est tout les épistémologie ce
temps observé ça c'est vrai il ya des
phases
et quand vous êtes à une nouvelle phase
en particulier dans les phases de
découverte
le conflit sont terrifiants alors quand
vous êtes dans une phase de découverte
les conflits sont terrifiants fabrice di
vizio comment est ce que vous comprenez
cette prise de parole ça m'épuise pardon
mais avec lui parce que franchement
veille le spectacle qu'ont afro français
dans la farine restons raisonnables de
minutes quoi on se bat effectivement
compris l'épidémie et vous avez la
commission denquête qui calmement
tranquillement vient auditionne des
professeurs dans la méthodologie les
pistes et biologie je peux vous dire des
choses calmement et franchement on s'en
fout complètement d'accord finalement
donné pour les céréales qui fait son job
il le fait bien ou mal ça ses pairs qui
le disent c'est assez peur de le dire
mais à un moment donné effectivement je
me demande quel était l'intérêt tant
pour professeur avoue que d'un côté que
pour effectivement la commission d
enquête
de cette espèce d'épisodes espèce de
propos sur la recherche fondamentale sur
les pistes et biologie surtout ça gère
pardon mais on s'en fout complètement
frédéric saint clair on est à côté de la
plaque avec ce jeu ce type de parole
lors de cette audition selon vous vous
rejoignez les propos de fabrice division
non je crois que dans une audition de
deux heures
bien évidemment on n'aborde pas les
problèmes de façon strictement ordonné
rationnel avec un point de vue derrière
chaque question la parole elle est libre
et viennent sur le tapis des
problématiques qui sont liées de près ou
de loin à celle qui nous à celle qui
nous occupe
la question c'est en quoi la
problématique soulevée par le professeur
raoul peut-être lié à ce que nous avons
vécu et ça rejoint ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure
en réalité on a vécu les français ont
vécu majoritairement un conflit de la
parole scientifique les pour la pour la
première fois parce que quand il ya un
désaccord sur la façon de lancer un
satellite dans l'espace ça reste ça
reste immédiat teaser que on n'a pas
accès à ce qui se passe or là les
médecins tous types de médecins
confondues et tous types de deux
positions médical confondues sont venus
directement sur les plateaux télévisés
pour s'adresser aux français et les
français ont vu pendant toute cette
période là que la science progresser
parlera pas de façon contradictoire pas
un médecin ne disait la même chose que
le suivant alors on a vu qu'il y avait
des groupes de médecins qui étaient
d'accord il ya encore aujourd'hui 500
médecins qui ont porté plainte contre le
professeur raoul il y en a 200 qui se
sont portés à son crédit en disant mais
laissez le travailler
donc vous voyez bien que ce dont ils
parlent
finalement c'est la traduction en termes
épistémologique
donc c'est à dire en termes de
philosophie des sciences de ce que nous
avons vécu mais
dia tic mans pendant trois mois c'est à
dire la façon dans la parole
scientifique
impact 1 les pouvoirs publics de
l'opinion publique et 3 la façon dont
elles mêmes se construit et bataille de
façon visible dans les médias et de
façon invisible à travers les revues
fabrice di vizio il nous reste quelques
secondes le mot de la fin où vous a
senti agacé à plusieurs reprises la
femme le mot de la fin mais je sais que
tout ça les français s'en foutent ils en
ont marre d'entendre des médecins se
battre au détriment de leur santé
si les médecins effectivement la
majorité des médecins monsieur ne court
pas les plateaux tv
la majorité des médecins monsieur sont
dans leurs cabinets en train de sauver
des vies et c'est ça que je retiens de
cette épidémie
c'est que la majorité silencieuse c'est
elle qui fait la médecine et que l on
l'a pas entendu parce qu'elle bossait
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
apporté votre décryptage fabrice di
vizio je rappelle que vous êtes avocat
d'une association de victimes de
coronavirus frédéric sinclair
éditorialiste politique